we attend school to gain knowledge about
history mathematics art and science but
not everything may teach us in school is
based on facts if you're new to our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
because today we're telling you the
truth about 10 outrageous lies you were
taught in school we only use 10% of our
brains most students are taught that
humans only use 10% of their brain but
this couldn't be any further from the
truth
according to neurologists humans used
virtually every part of their brain and
most of the brain is active almost all
of the time so where exactly did the
myths that we only use a tiny portion of
our brains come from many people believe
it all started with the myth quote from
Albert Einstein Thanksgiving in schools
were taught that the pilgrims arrived at
Plymouth Rock on the Mayflower the harsh
winter was so severe and they were
unprepared for the conditions that's
when the natives arrived and gave them
food and taught them how to plant corn
they then commemorated the hardships
they went through with the yearly
celebration which is now called
Thanksgiving that's the story that's
taught in schools is absolutely false
when the pilgrims arrived they brought
along with them a plague that wiped out
nearly the entire Native American
population they stole their land and
turn the strong natives into their
slaves diamonds are made from coal many
people still believe diamonds are made
from coal but I'm sorry to break it to
you this just isn't true at all diamonds
are made out of a highly organized
carbon maybe teachers thought the story
of turning coals into diamonds would
impress students more than telling them
the actual truth but we now know if it
sounds too good to be true it probably
is I before E except after seen while
learning how to spell many teachers
taught their students the general rule
of I before E except after C it's just
too bad this rule doesn't really apply
there are violations to this rule all
throughout the English language perhaps
it's about time teachers change the rule
to I before E except in words such as
eight protein Einstein and many more our
taste buds schools teach students that
the ton is divided into four areas and
each area is used to detect sweet sour
salty and bitter taste we were taught
that the salt taste buds were on both
sides of the front of the tongue but if
you placed a bit of salt on the tip of
your tongue you're still able to taste
it so what did
the truth is the entire surface of the
tongue has the ability to detect tape
perhaps teachers thought that teaching
this lie about our tongue being divided
into different tasting sections was a
bit more fascinating than telling us the
truth red yellow and blue are primary
colors you're our teacher probably
taught you that red yellow and blue are
primary colors but they lied for no good
reason the true primary colors of cyan
yellow and magenta so why the teachers
give us the wrong information all our
lives maybe they thought young kids
couldn't pronounce fancy words such as
cyan and magenta so they replaced them
with blue and red instead deoxygenated
blood is blue there's absolutely no
truth behind the myth that the
oxygenated blood is blue this lie is
based on the fact that veins appear blue
underneath the skin so many teachers
taught their students that the blood
turned red once it was exposed to oxygen
the truth is our veins appear blue
because of the way our eyes perceive
colors teachers probably thought this
concept was a little too advanced to
teach young kids so they made up the lie
about deoxygenated blood turning blue
instead cursive is an essential skill
curriculums that teach students how to
write in cursive have slowly disappeared
from all classrooms but there was a time
when teachers lied and told us that
writing in cursive was an essential
skill we all needed in life cursive has
since been replaced by typing on a
computer and texting and schools finally
decided that learning how to write in
cursive was one skill that just wasn't
that important the North Star is the
brightest star while in school teachers
taught us if we ever get lost just look
up in the sky to locate the North Star
it shouldn't be hard to miss since it's
the brightest star in the sky right
wrong the North Star is actually the
fiftieth brightest star in our solar
system there's no gravity in space while
learning about astronomy many teachers
taught us a lie that there's no gravity
in outer space although this myth has
been debunked for years many schools
still teach this outdated concept the
truth is there's definitely gravity in
space it's just that a much weaker value
what other lies have you been taught in
school leave us a comment down below and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up
[Music]
you